[Music]
despite the traditional pageantry there
was as much focus on Scotland's future
as its past and the debating chamber
audience were twenty year olds born on
the very day the Scottish Parliament was
opened the children of the devolution as
they've become known heard the Queen
reflect on a place established not just
for talking but of course it must also
be a place to listen a place to hear
views that inevitably made different
quite considerably one from another and
a place to honor those views in turn
this occasion today gives us all an
opportunity to honor those who helped
turn talk into action from the First
Minister Nicola Sturgeon that was just a
passing reference to the current
political crisis in times of course when
politics can seem more divisive and
confrontational than ever I hope we will
maintain our commitment to working
together working together in the common
good
[Music]
when it comes to loyalty those now the
same age as the Scottish Parliament
itself have no doubt about which place
enjoys their allegiance with less
Manasseh is quite distant because a lot
of the policies they make added base
within Scotland the art based because
England as significantly larger than
Scotland is that kind of deference and
doing that I think for me and I feel
closer to scratch moment I say it's
personally I think that's the Scottish
Parliament has been weak a really good
thing for us just because as very people
based I live in Scotland and as our
Parliament's are as important so I mean
otherwise we follow politics like it's
so doesn't mean a lot to me because it's
Scotland when the Queen opened the
Holyrood Parliament building in 1999
there was much optimism for Scotland's
future twenty years on the Scottish
Parliament stands at a crossroads
although the Queen was never going to
mention the b-word she will of course be
only too aware of the potential stresses
and strains brexit may place on the
union between Scotland and the rest of
the United Kingdom Mike McCarthy Sky
News Edinburgh